reunidos frente a un edificio del
gobierno local serbios étnicos
intentaron impedir la entrada del
alcalde albanés recién elegido fue una
de las tantas protestas que se llevaron
a cabo el viernes en el norte de kosovo
en la que se produjeron violentos
enfrentamientos entre la policía y los
manifestantes
la policía utilizó gases lacrimógenos y
granadas aturdidoras mientras que varios
coches fueron incendiados
me arrastraron entre dos coches
empezaron a golpearme como pueden ver
aquí tengo una herida y tengo heridas en
el cuerpo
las tensiones tienen origen en las
elecciones anticipadas celebradas el 23
de abril en cuatro municipios de mayoría
Serbia después de que sus representantes
dimitieran en protesta del año pasado
los comicios fueron boicoteados en gran
medida por los serbios y la
participación electoral fue inferior al
3,5%, los alcaldes de etnia albanesa
recién elegidos intentaron tomar
posesión de sus cargos el viernes lo que
provocó más
Serbia ha puesto a su ejército en alerta
máxima y ha ordenado el envío de fuerzas
hacia la frontera una medida que ha
adoptado repetidamente en los últimos
años protegeremos y pediremos la paz
luchare por cada segundo de paz para que
dure más pero les digo que ante el
primer ataque contra serbios en el norte
de kosovo y mitología servía no se
quedará de brazos cruzados
Estados Unidos y la Unión Europea
condenaron la investidura de los nuevos
alcaldes y Washington dijo que la medida
de Belgrado de enviar tropas a la
frontera era innecesaria kosovo declaró
su independencia de Serbia en 2008
aunque los serbios de la región
septentrional siguen considerando
Belgrado como su capital